[Musik]
hinunter gegangen
dort habe ich die beobachten die kinder
in goldminen arbeiten und manchmal ums
leben
mit seinem lokal verschafft
pfarrer kaviar becks ledigen müttern
arbeit und finanziert kinderheime für
die opfer des goldrausches im
peruanischen urwald stadt marl videos
[Musik]
folgen das wieder nach oben zu gehen
ihre kinder zu retten
hier gibt es die besten klassen von peru
wenn nicht überhaupt von der ganzen welt
muss die tus den polar die kleinen
vergnügen des pfarrers so heißt die
eisdiele in der hauptstadt port gott
maldonado wogegen aber richtet sich sein
großes missvergnügen deshalb tragen ihm
seine predigten morddrohungen ein
davon handelt dieser bericht von einer
großen traurigen geschichte in einigen
kleinen geschichten welche die große
etwas erträglicher machen
[Musik]
die große geschichte ist rasch erzählt
mit dem preis des metalls stieg das
fieber der goldgräber der raubzug machte
grüne landstriche zu wüsten immer mehr
menschen zogen in den wilden osten perus
um ihr glück zu suchen ohne segen der
behörde ohne rücksicht auf die natur das
gold aber das dreckige gold aus peru
landete zum großen teil in den gold
schmelzen der schweiz
eine der vielen kleinen geschichten die
badehalle angezettelt hat beginnt hier
in dieser papeterie hier in der urwald
stadt puerto maldonado eröffnet hat nur
um hier das schulmaterial billiger zu
verkaufen als die überteuerte konkurrenz
nieder denken sein können damit damit
das wäre nicht so teuer
kammer vom golf von aden
die provinz mare de dios ist zweimal so
groß wie die schweiz und zählt kaum
200.000 einwohner aber die hauptstadt
puerto maldonado am zusammenfluss zwei
amazonas zubringer gelegen ist die am
schnellsten wachsende stadt perus die
kunde vom gold hat viele bewohner aus
der hochebene tanken ins tiefland
gelockt auf den markt finden sie
kokablätter und andere produkte aus
ihrer heimat und hier gewöhnen sie sich
an die tropischen sekte des urwaldes
aber reich geworden sind wenige und die
illusion des goldes verschafft höchstens
ein getränk aus japan frucht machen
eine fahrt den fluss marius hinauf zeigt
rasch dass der traum vom schnellen
reichtum kaum zu unterdrücken ist vor
zwei jahren hat beruht informelle
goldgräber verboten
immer wieder springt die polizei wo
maschinen in die luft jetzt herrscht in
marius sein klima der unsicherheit
mit der wachsenden sozialen not setzen
sich auch diese kleinen geschichten fort
die babiel der großen entgegenstellt wir
sind hier im kinderheim der kleine prinz
gegründet von der vereinigung zum schutz
von kindern und jugendlichen begleitet
von drei heraus buben eigentlich schon
fast terroristen 30 kinder leben in
seinen beiden heimen gott zu zehn
jugendliche die stipendien erhalten für
ihr studium das spielgerät für die
kinder hatte pfarrer selber entworfen
[Gelächter]
und er ist großartig gewesen dass ich
die genauso wie der repräsentation kopie
vom gerät von der schule von hakon ganz
gleich wie eine familie
sie gehen in der schule sie werden ihre
kameraden einladen
sie können spezielle kurse für
musik oder irgendwas wie eine familie
habe leitete ein kinderheim in genf
bevor mit 30 jahren nach peru kam als
ich 15 war war ich schon entschlossen in
die dritte welt zu gehen und ich nahm
mir vor glücklich zu sein denn ich
wollte nicht in die dritte welt gehen
und probleme zu exportieren
stattdessen hat er drei kinder adoptiert
jetzt ist der katholische priester
mehrfacher großvater die ganze familie
ist hier das ist meine familie
und das ist jessica hat die älteste und
der kleine der heißt auch hier wie ich
es ist zum tag und henry das älteste der
drei adoptivkinder fährt mit seiner
familie zur messe
andrä hat journalismus studiert moment
ist er ohne arbeit
seine frau lady arbeitet als
krankenschwester
der kleine hat er hat im gleichen tag
geburtstag wie sein großvater heute ist
der tag der tiere der welt fragt der
tiere
der tag des heiligen franziskus darüber
werden wir heute reden selten beschenkt
sich rami in seinen predigten auf promi
bibelworte kaviar becks ist die frames
theologe und für seine verkündigung
nimmt er die konkreten lebensumstände
seiner gläubigen ratsvorlage und so
erstaunt es niemanden dass der bahre von
den tieren rasch auf die situation der
minenarbeiter zu sprechen kommt denen
die regierung ihre tätigkeit verbieten
will
[Musik]
ich würde es begrüßen wenn diese minen
tätigkeit aufhört die bringt überhaupt
nichts gutes aber wir können sie nicht
einfach verbieten wovon sollen wir sonst
essen
das heißt wir müssen eine art der
goldgräber erfinden die nicht derart
zerstörerisch ist das ist möglich man
kann wieder aufforsten
man kann das verbrannte öl auffangen man
kann aufhören sie flüsse mit quecksilber
zu verschmutzen
auf den großvater warten eine taufe und
weitere messen die familie des sohnes
freut sich auf ein besonderes vergnügen
am sonntäglichen markt verkaufen lokale
produzenten ihre ware und hier gibt es
suri kost der urwaldbewohner die larve
eines palm käfers gegrillt und am spieß
gerühmt als jungbrunnen und kraft spende
für kleine und große kinder
und hier gibt es auch die fische aus den
lokalen flüssen deren verzehr nach
jahren der goldgelbe rey
gesundheitsschädlich geworden ist eine
studie im spital von madre de dios hat
gezeigt dass menschen die viel fisch
essen mit dem quecksilber kontaminiert
sind
das quecksilber ist in den bächen und
flüssen und verseucht die fische aber
klar die leute hier essen weiterhin in
fisch weil sie es nicht anders wissen
aus unkenntnis und fehlender bildung
[Musik]
unterwegs mit henry und seinem freund
peer israel ein goldgräber lager bei st
der fahrer ist mit einer 5 mm braunen
bewaffnet fremde sind hier nicht
willkommen die leute hier verbinden
jeden gringo mit umweltschützern und
umweltschutz verbinden sie mit personen
die ihnen die arbeit verbieten wollen
deshalb wolle keinen besuch und so
beobachten wir die arbeit in der
goldmine von frau notariats neugierige
touristen und mit einer kleinen kamera
zwei männer wechseln sich während 24
stunden an der pumpstation ab sie sorgen
dafür dass das saugrohr unaufhörlich
kies und sand in die höhe bringt
die arbeitsbedingungen sind prekär aber
die arbeiter erhalten je 25 prozent des
gewaschenen goldes und können damit in
wenigen tagen mehr verdienen als einen
gesetzlich vorgeschriebenen monatliche
minimal um die gold splitter bleiben
zusammen mit feinem schlamm in einem
teppich hängen der hier bereits
ausgeknockt wurde henry ist das alles
nichts neues
er hat als kind in den goldminen
gearbeitet jetzt bestellen schlamm aus
damit sich das quecksilber mit dem gut
verbinden kann ohne jede vorsicht bringt
der arbeitet das quecksilber weg bis nur
noch das reine grund übrig bleibt
[Musik]
kaviar becks besuchte die stifter schule
des klosters engelberg und bildete sich
in genf zum jugendarbeiter aus bevor er
in peru auf das problem der
unkontrollierten grund kletterei stieß
als ich kam waren die kinder das problem
kinder die aus den anden runterkamen von
10 11 16 jahren
sie arbeiteten mit schnitt kam während
dreier monate karten sind 100 mal
täglich erdmaterial weg das war der
vertrag
das war ihre arbeit aber viele kehrten
nie mehr nach hause zurück
[Musik]
auf dem weg nach masuko an den fuß der
anden zu pfarrer h wie es erst im
kinderheim wo seine adoptiv sohn henry
aufwuchs vorbei an den spuren des gold
fiebers
meine mutter suchte das abenteuer den
dörfern daran gab es nichts zu verdienen
deshalb ging sie weg und tatsächlich sie
warnt gold damit kamen sie zurück um
ihre fünf kinder zu holen
mein bruder und ich waren so 78 jährige
und es war das paradies es hatte affen
an texten fische es hat er viele früchte
begonnen
der ganze urwald meine mutter wollte
dass die schwestern war tränen die
schule gehen und es gab nur hier
sekundarschule und so kommt meine mutter
nach masuko und bringt uns in einem haus
unter wo die familie genauer um die
parteien monat voraus für essen und
unterkunft
sie sagte in einem monat komme ich
wieder
aber das war das letzte mal dass ich
meine mutter sah das letzte mal die
mutter kam nicht zurück und henry
neunjährige arbeitete in einer goldmine
er spülte geschirr und schleppte wasser
verdiente 1 gramm gold im monat
die familie bei der die mutter sie
zurückgelassen hatte brachte die kinder
zu pari
und ich fragte ihn was muss ich tun ich
muss arbeiten sonst gibt es nichts zu
essen
er sagte bloss 9g spielen spielen das
ist das mein herz war hart geworden oder
die realität so erdrückend dass ich
nicht mehr wusste was das war kommt
essen wie seltsam ich komme zur tür
herein und zum ersten mal einen
gedeckten tisch mit alt in vielen sachen
das kam mir sehr seltsam vor
denn ich sagte ich muss arbeiten woher
kommt das alles ist ein zauber es ist
zauberer
das hat hier mit uns gemacht haben die
schmerzen vergessen und es ist ihm
gelungen unsere herzen zu lösen
da habe ich begonnen zu spielen
[Musik]
auf dem heimweg kommen wir am
berüchtigten kilometer 108 der straße
nach cusco vorbei wo krämer und [ __ ]
den goldgräbern helfen ihren verdienst
rasch wieder loszuwerden
[Musik]
kumulativ ergibt die leute hier die
einfachen leute behaupten dass gold
gehört dem teufel damit die erde das
gold hergibt muss jemand sterben
jemand muss unter den boden kommen damit
der teufel das gold hergibt
was ist bloß dass es viele tote gibt die
werden irgendwo verscharrt nachdem sie
vom schlamm begraben oder von einem
erdrutsch erfasst wurden es gibt mütter
die ewig auf ihre söhne warten frauen
der männer wie zurückkehren das gibt es
in der goldgräber viele tote
[Musik]
es ist alles sehr schwierig hier
denn es geht nicht um große unternehmen
es sind tausende und tausende von
kleinen und die kleinen hier haben eine
kultur der wilden räuberei es kümmert
sie nicht dass ihre handlanger sterben
es kümmert sie nicht das quecksilber zu
verschleudern das ganze gebrauchte öl im
wald zu verbieten
davon spricht niemand seit jahren
prangert pavia airbags die sozialen und
ökologischen probleme der goldgräber an
jetzt wo die regierung das problem mit
einem verbot lösen will setzt er sich
für die kleinen ein
die regierung sagt wenn es so ist
schmeißen wir alle kleinen raus und
bringen große er und die großen werden
die regeln einhalten
und ich stelle mir vor dass die
schweizer goldkäufer das gleiche wollen
dass die wilden räuber gehen und das
durch krawattenträger kommen die ein
sauberes gold produzieren wie schon der
ziegler sagte die schweiz wäscht weisser
aber wenn du 20.000 arbeitsplätze
eliminiert um sie so zu nennen mögen sie
auch informell ungesetzlich und strecken
seien es in 20.000 arbeitsplätze und
wenn du sie wegnimmt was wirst du tun
ich sage der regierung gehen wir schritt
für schritt vor aber das will die
regierung nicht
jetzt haben sie ihn verkauf des diesels
eingeschränkt um damit die goldgräber zu
bremsen
aber das gegenteil ist der fall die
produzieren jetzt ihren eigenen
schwarzen mafiösen brennstoff und der
ist schädlicher als derjenige vorher
ich denke nicht entschuldigen regierung
aber es sieht aus als ob du dir nichts
überlegt
ein einziger schweizer goldhändler hat
innert weniger jahre 60 tonnen gold
verdächtigen ursprungs gekauft jetzt
predigt badrawi den schweizerischen gold
schmelzen und rohstoffhändlern ins
gewissen
sie soll nur noch sozial und
umweltverträglich produziertes gold
kaufen
apart erde
sie müssten bloß sagen ab dem 31 august
2016 zb kaufen wir kein gold mehr das
nicht zu diesen diesen und diesen
bedingungen produziert wurde
die käufer sind es welche die lösung in
der hand haben denn wie soll es hier
geschehen wenn alle die mit gold zu tun
haben verhängt sind über erpressung
mafia und ähnliches hier in peru ist es
schwierig 250 kindern hat barbie ein
heim gegeben 65 arbeitsplätze hatte
geschaffen und manchmal mischte sich
auch in die große geschichte ein und
fährt den mächtigen an den karren
es ist der wunsch etwas zu tun damit das
eigene leben in einem gewissen sinn
bekommen einen beitrag zu leisten für
etwas mehr menschlichkeit
das ist der jüngste streich des pfarrers
bos sonntag einen touristen lodge die
ebenfalls mithelfen solchen kinderheime
zu finanzieren
die attraktion hier ist die hängebrücke
auf einen 40 meter hohen urwaldriesen in
unzerstörten dschungel von madre de dios
der ausblick ist prächtig nur fehlen die
touristen
wir wollen dass unsere gäste gut
behandelt werden
jeder als einzelne person und nicht als
gruppe wir wollen dass das ganze
personal von hier kommt und auch der
verdienst hier bleibt und das gefällt
halt eine reiseagentur nicht aber der
priester hat sich schon eine neue
geschichte ausgedacht um das loch in der
kasse zu füllen
eine kaffeeplantage das beste stück ist
von der schweiz die besten pflanzen
material vom jki
das sind diese pflanzen und jetzt kann
sich auch jeder vorstellen wo aus das
nächste kleine vergnügen des pfarrers
besteht
wir aber haben eine letzte frage in die
arbeitswelt das gefühl des glücks immer
noch an das glück besteht darin dass du
etwas bewegt und ich glaube dass ich
etwas bewirken und das macht dich
glücklich auf jeden fall die zuneigung
der menschen zu spüren auch wenn es
solche gibt die mich nicht mögen und
viele wollen mich auch umbringen
aber das gehört hier zum spiel und
insgesamt ist es nicht gefährlicher als
in europa autobahn
[Musik]